halt diesmal ohne kapuze 21 hey was geht
ab netz willkommen beim ein video und
zwar habe ich heute meinen bruder dabei
vielleicht kennen der eine oder andere
von euch ja schon
du kannst ja einfach mal vorstellen ich
bin sein bruder merlin und bin 14 jahre
alt genau und nein
dressed erfahrt ihr und wir haben uns
gedacht wir machen einfach mal es gibt
so ein geschwister tag und den machen
wir einfach mal das sind halt acht
fragen haben uns ausgesucht die dann hat
er über mich beantworten muss und ich im
gegenzug auch über ihn und ja würden gar
nicht lange glauben wollen und direkt
mal anfangen falls ich will das noch
nach oben da und auch rein
viel spaß die erste frage wäre was ist
dein lieblingsessen also ich war jetzt
ein mann
ich würde sagen also es ist einfach so
egal wo wir sind selbst wenn wir im
urlaub sind und das richtig geile sachen
gibt der spaghetti und tipps auch mal
spaghetti und deswegen jeezy mal
spaghetti ist dein lieblingsessen
oder oder auch fast so langsam ihr
dasein
du wirst eigentlich fast überall burger
und fängt ja auch nicht wirklich was
eigentlich erst wenn auch sehr gerne
pizza folgen dieses hawaii flitzer wo
sogar bei toast hawaii toast weißt du
dass er sich auch noch gerne und jörg
berger und das ja das stimmt schon die
nächste frage wer wann man geburtstag
hat also welcher monat werden im
november geburtstag weißt du wie der tag
weiß ich bei meinen eltern nicht mal bei
der tour dritter november als wales
september der 16
september als nächstes wäre die frage
der klamotten stil also ich würde bei
dir sagen du hast ja schon eigentlich
ziemlich viele sachen aber du benutzt
sich diese ziemlich viele sachen sondern
sich sehr auf das was an also das an was
die am besten gefällt und nicht das was
auch noch so im schrank ist dann sagt ja
wenn man mal was anderes an
oder ich schätze aber jetzt es so du
kaufst du auch ganz viele sachen also so
als sackgasse für sachen pullover mit
frauen drauf und sowas da habe ich nur
drei und halt jeans und schwarze hosen
als dies mit ohne kapuze
dies kann auch da reinkommen
betis ohne kapuze ist das ausgesprochen
dies ohne kapuze monat mit ja ohne
herzen jetzt also ich trag auch er
lieber engere busen als diese weiteren
auch sobald also ja schon die nächste
farbe wäre die lieblingswaffe nächste
farbe wäre die lieblingsfarbe nächste
frage nächste frage
nächste frage wer die lieblingsfarben
also lieblingsfarbe von händlern
doch wahrscheinlich mehr
rot grün habe ich seit meine
lieblingsfarbe immer seitdem ich fünf
bin schon die gleiche lieblings habe
sich frühere folge der blog
ich mag den blauen noch nie ich habe
immer weil alle blau machen hab ich
gesagt nee ich mag ich glaub ich mag
auch nicht rot sondern grün
nächste frage wäre die
lieblingsbeschäftigung ich würde bei dir
sagen hausaufgaben machen ist es
definitiv nicht
laptop spielen also irgendwelche
gamestop eventuell wer halt schon so
ziemlich weit oben oder inliner fahren
also schon sorgen inliner und fussball
fussball
du spielst mir während ein fußballspiel
im fußball ich bin oft bei dir ist das
so
videos machen und videos schneiden
verbringt jetzt auch in vielleicht drei
stunden womit dann fernsehen gucken ja
auch nicht so aber mit deinen freunden
gezogen also nächste frage ist
lieblingsgetränk ich würde bei dir sagen
ja und bei mir ein bier trinkt auch
immer überall hier weil ich nicht euch
die kollektiven will ich mache ab und zu
jetzt übrigens live streams auf juno
link dazu ist in der infobox könnt ihr
ab checken und folgen dann verpasste das
nächste frage hatte die nächste frage
wer die dümmste angewohnheit die er oder
ich habe wo sie erst mal überlegen was
bei mir was ich werde mal wohl
überlappen kompletten die banken konnten
ja ok ja das stimmt schon aber das hier
nicht dumm das ist ja nur selbst wenn du
halt hochgehen sollte und irgendwas
lernen sollst dann lernst du nicht so
einfach irgendwas anderes zum beispiel
computer oder computer oder eventuell
auch computer also ich weiss nicht
stimmt das könnte man als dumme
angewohnheit sehen muss man aber nicht
also die letzte frage wer da noch
lieblingsspiele also wir spielen ja
schon gerne gegen welche konsolen
computer und mit super lieblingsgames
also nicht gesellschaftsspiele
lieblingsgames 15
ja also stimmt schon ich hatte fieber 15
uhr bis vor drei tagen ich war selber
aber jetzt ist es halt schon mein
lieblingsspiel ich würde bei dir sagen
sein lieblings spiel ist obwohl du
gerade mal 14 bist nicht irgendwas was
auf dich zutrifft sondern er irgendwas
was ab 16 oder eventuell auch am 18
black ops oder black ops oder combat
arms
im spiel oder news at paradise city das
ist so ein auto wenn das geht so es aus
sechs nationen
ja sollte dann so viel darf ich würde
jetzt mal sagen falls ihr ab und zu noch
mal wieder mit ihm sehen wollte last auf
jeden fall noch nach oben
hier ist doch sein instagram eingebildet
falls ihr mal vorbeischauen wollte hier
ist meins eingeblendet also könnt ihr
bei ihrer folgen oder so und wir sehen
uns in den nächsten drei tage oder so
wieder hier auf der linken seite geht es
weiter mit dem letzten judas war dinge
die du niemals zu meiner freude sagen
wolltest und hier auf der anderen seite
bitte lasst euch überraschen
ich würde sagen abonnieren nicht
vergessen und zwei drei leute